[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro d' europe hebdo ici au
parlement européen à bruxelles dans
cette édition nous mettons le cap sur
l'irlande au coeur du débat européen
depuis deux ans et le début des
négociations sur le brésil
quid du moral des irlandais alors que la
sortie du royaume uni de l'union
européenne fait planer la crainte d'un
retour d'une frontière physique sur
l'île scénario qui mettrait en péril les
accords du vendredi saint qui ont mis
fin à 30 ans de guerre civile
mais l'irlande c'est aussi un pays de
forte tradition catholique qui a
libéralisé l'avortement en début d'année
nous parlerons enfin du retour du fameux
tigre celtique en bonne forme économique
malgré des années d'austérité
reportage à suivre dans cette émission
et nous en discuterons bien sûr avec nos
invités
mais je vous propose d'abord de nous
arrêter sur l'initiative de cette start
up de lobbying citoyen qui a organisé
une très large consultation d'habitants
de l'union européenne
un bon moyen de prendre la température à
quelques semaines du scrutin européen
michael spitzberg est allé à la
rencontre de ses créateurs voyez son
reportage
[Musique]
comment réinventer l'europe concrètement
c'est la question qu'on posait deux
associations citoyennes aux habitants de
l'union européenne 1 million 700 mille
personnes ont été interrogées soit la
plus vaste consultation jamais organisé
en europe
trente mille propositions ont été
recueillis premiers renseignements
cinq thèmes concentrent les principales
préoccupations des européens en tête
l'environnement suivi par la démocratie
avec des disparités géographiques
pour ce qui est par exemple du soutien
de l'éducation on voit que ça marchera
mieux dans les pays l'est que dans les
pays où est son système négatif et puis
développer les parts contre le sou qui a
une proposition pour taxer
multinationales on voit que c'est
beaucoup plus un sujet de p l'ouest pays
courent déjà d'état providence bien fort
bien établi et un petit peu mois dans
les pays l'est
au final dix propositions phares pour
l'ensemble des européens ont émergé d'un
vaste programme de recyclage des habits
à la protection des droits des
travailleurs dans mes interactions avec
les citoyens eh bien ce sont ces
préoccupations là qui ressortent
le problème c'est qu'elles ne sont pas
prises en couvrir nos concitoyens
beaucoup se disent mais nos politiciens
ils nous écoutent pas pour choisir les
dix propositions phares vont être
soumises aux candidats aux élections
européennes on va aller voir les 1000
partis nationaux candidats aux élections
européennes dans tous les pays de
l'union pour les engagés à prendre une
position très claire sur ces des
propositions les électeurs européens ont
rendez-vous dans les urnes du 23 au 26
mai prochain
et pour parler de cette consultation et
plus largement des attentes des citoyens
européens j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir
sur ce plateau et me aurélie bonjour
bonjour vous êtes irlandaise ancien
journaliste et depuis 2013 d'être la
médiatrice de l'union européenne alors
on va commencer d'abord par rappeler
rapidement quel rôle vous jouez au sein
des institutions en fait vous recevez
les plaintes d'entreprises citoyens ong
européennes environ 2500 plaintes par an
qui porte essentiellement sur la
transparence dans les institutions alors
on l'a vu dans le reportage ans est un
sujet qui ressort en de cette
consultation voyait d'ailleurs ce que
réclame sept espagnols proposent fouet
ma proposition est de pouvoir disposer
d'informations claires et transparentes
sur l'ensemble des décisions des projets
et désaccords au sein de l'union
européenne
pour moi c'est aussi une façon de rester
unis alors selon vous aimiez aurélie
pourquoi il ya cette distance cette ce
manque de confiance des européens
vis-à-vis de leurs institutions
vous savez le lendemain après le la
question la plus posée à les
britanniques à gogo était qu'est ce que
c'est les unit entre européens
il y avait 1 complète manque de
compréhension de connaissances l'union
européenne aucune élection importante de
connaissances qui se manque de confiance
bien sûr ce n'était pas là
la seule raison pour la décision de
sortir de l'union et c'était très
important
est ce que j'essaie de faire en tant que
médiatrice de renforcer les liens entre
les institutions et les citoyens
exemple j'ai fait en enquête dans la
transparence du conseil
c'est à dire les représentants des états
membres qui vient après celle pour faire
des lois beaucoup de gens je crois que
je crois que c'est la crème commission
les fonctionnaires invisible qui font
les lois mais c'est pas ça c'est une
autre député élu au parlement européen
et notre propre ministre qui vont
pousser pour ferrer les régulations ce
que j'ai recommandé qu'on sait c'est de
fait plus transparente ce qu'ils font au
même d'enregistrer les positions prises
pour arnaud est un moment quand ils le
font des lois alors vous recevez aussi
beaucoup de plantes de citoyens
européens qui se plaignent de leurs
responsables nationaux qu'est ce que
vous faites dans ce cas là beaucoup de
points sont pas contre les institutions
plus un pays en mai contre leur propre
administration propre gouvernement
donc je leur conseille pas d'être allé
au médiateur
chez chez eux allés aux couleurs
médiateur national
oui oui mais je nous ai dans les rues
chez nous alors au niveau des
institutions européennes en tout cas on
a deux grandes affaires en tête il ya
d'abord la nomination express de martin
celle mayer a qui était l'ancien bras
droit de jean claude juncker au poste de
secrétaire général de la commission
européenne y aussi le cas de josé manuel
barosso ancien président de la
commission européenne qui est accusé de
faire du lobbying au profit de la banque
goldman sachs auprès de l'exécutif
européen
qu'est ce que vous avez fait pour ses
besoins deux cas c'est différent mais
avec le même résultat ça c'est
d'abaisser la confiance je crois dans
les institutions
et ça c'est dommage au cas de monsieur
barroso l'ancien président de la
commission elle avait décidé de
l'accepter
un poste dans le coma saxo bank bank
assez controversée après la crise
financière et du lobbying aujourd'hui
auprès de l'exécutif européen
oui je compte j'ai fait en catch et j'ai
fait des recommandations aux commissions
de renforcer la cour de conduite qui
gère le travail peut demander des
commissaires et des présidents de la
commission
ils ont fait ça et dans le cas de
monsieur seulement le secrétaire général
de la commission
j'ai reçu des plantes un g j'ai fait un
enquête dont la manière dont la
commission avait traité la nomination de
monsieur seulement et j'ai fait une
recommandation que le prochaine fois il
faut être plus transparent dans la
manière dont on la commission mais votre
avis n'est que consultatif finalement
est ce que votre action peut peut-être
véritablement être efficace ah oui oui
je trouve parce que dans la plupart de
cale les institutions acceptent mes
recommandations de 80 % jusqu'à 90% des
recommandations que je vais y sont
acceptés par les institutions et même si
je n'obtiens pas tout ce que je veux
j'ai fait des progrès alors je voudrais
maintenant que l'on écoute la
proposition de jules un jeune belge qui
dénonce les fassions l'évasion fiscale
de certaines grandes entreprises
internationales
on entend souvent les multinationales
avec ryanair par exemple ya beaucoup de
soucis y payent leurs impôts uniquement
en irlande alors que les travailleurs
sont basées en belgique
il ya les mêmes soucis avec apple ou
encore avec les géants du numérique qui
ne payent que très peu d'impôts par
rapport aux bénéfices qu'ils ont il faut
cesser les cadeaux fiscaux aux
multinationales
les entreprises doivent payer leur les
impôts dans les pays où sans générer les
bénéfices alors cette fiscalité
bienveillante ans elle est accordée
notamment aux gaffes aller géant
américain du net par certains états
membres de l'union européenne on pense
au luxembourg on pense à malte mais
aussi à l'irlande ans et votre pays
d'origine on voit qu'une taxation de ces
multinationales au niveau européen les
très difficile à mettre en place
justement parce que ses états membres
bloquent comment instaurer une fiscalité
plus juste comme le réclament les
citoyens oui comme vous savez la matière
de l'impôt sur les sociétés est matière
très contestée parmi les états membres
veulent donner ce qu'ils veulent qu elle
soit une compétence à l'union il ya
d'autres communes en eau qui veut qu'il
reste chez les états membres mais je
crois que le problème est que beaucoup
de gens et des politiciens et des
administrations ne font pas le lien
entre la position les impôts
injuste ilan égalité global parce que si
il ya des pays surtout des pays pauvres
qui ne soient pas des impôts d'état ça
risque de rendre plus pauvres les
citoyens alors toute dernière question à
qui s'adresse plus à l'ancien
journaliste que vous avez été pendant
des années en irlande dans ce pays qui
va être l'objet de la deuxième partie de
notre émission et qui est malgré lui au
coeur du débat européen avec cette
question du breakbeat et ses inquiétudes
qui tourne autour de cette sortie du
royaume uni de l'union européenne quel
est le sentiment des irlandais sur cette
question selon vous à quelques semaines
du scrutin européen
ouais bien sûr nous 113 enquête parce
que c'est un problème très grave points
2 passes que les liens entre nous et le
royaume uni sont très compliqué et très
dur aussi au sein de la politique
l'économie mais surtout la paix parce
qu'après le processus de paix de l'ua 21
je crois il n'y avait pas un beau en
frontières dur oui il ya un chantier
mais ça ça reste en papier si vous aussi
vous traversé la frontière vous pourriez
pas vous ne saurez pas que vous allez
dans notre pays et ça c'est très très
important pour nous que nous avons le
soutien de presque tous les unions
augure bien mais je veux dire aussi que
cette société est remarquable que
pendant le référendum de principe
personne ne parle pas de la frontière et
après elle est devenue le point
d'achoppement dans les négociations
soient plus important est ce qui a
bloqué leur corps et âme you need de
sortir de l'union et on parlera
merci beaucoup et mignot serré
aujourd'hui sur votre fonction et sur
les attentes des citoyens à quelques
semaines de ce scrutin
nous passons maintenant à la suite de
notre tour d'europe avec un détour par
l'irlande un état membre au coeur du
débat européen depuis le début des
longues négociations sur le brésil pays
comptent près de cinq millions
d'habitants
son poids économique représente 1 73% du
pib de l'union européenne dont il est
membre depuis 1973 avec onze députés qui
le représente au parlement européen à sa
tête
président de la république aux pouvoirs
limités michael higgins issus des rangs
du parti travailliste et leo varadkar
jeune premier ministre de centre droit
depuis juin 2010 est notre reporter est
allé à la rencontre de ces irlandais
dont les yeux sont rivés sur le royaume
uni est à des lieues à sept semaines du
scrutin européen avec fabien becker
[Musique]
la france se les marchés ici c'est du
porte à porte
donc on voit chez les gens les
traditions politiques en irlande
sophie nicouleau les connais bien
installée à dublin depuis 2006 cette
française mariée à un irlandais milite
pour le parti des verts les tracts pour
l'élection européenne sont fraîchement
imprimés direction le quartier dj kore
sofia rendez vous avec le candidat
écologiste pour la circonscription de
dublin
c'est la première fois que je suis
candidat à l'élection européenne du
point de vue des vers l'europe a été
vecteur de nombreux progrès sociaux et
environnementaux en irlande
c'est donc important qu'en tant que
membre nous travaillons dans le cadre
européen pour continuer à peser sur les
décisions qui viennent de bruxelles le
24 mai en plus de leurs députés
les irlandais éliront leurs
représentants locaux sophie se présente
dans sa circonscription sous l'étiquette
des verts
aujourd'hui ces deux candidats
résolument pro européens font campagne
commune à quelques semaines du scrutin
des habitants ne pense pas encore
vraiment à l'élection européenne qu'il a
à nous en parlions à l'instant on n'y
pense même pas à cause du bric site
cela me paraît si loin la plupart des
gens autour de moi étaient affolés par
le break site
je pense qu'on est plus forts ensemble
les gens pensent à l'europe mais pas
encore en termes de parc
ils sont plutôt préoccupés par ce qu'il
se passe l'irlande ce petit pays de
moins de 5 millions d'habitants tout à
l'ouest de l'europe est suspendu à la
décision de son grand voisin le royaume
uni de quitter les lieux
dans les rues de dublin l'ombre du break
site ne fait que raviver le sentiment
pro-européen en ce moment certains en
europe voit lieu comme un problème mais
pas ici en irlande je pense que nous
sommes le pays qui aime le plus l'union
européenne est bonne pour l'irlande et
l'irlande est bonne pour l'europe
nous sommes un petit pays isolé nous
avons besoin de l'europe et j'espère que
nous resterons toujours dans le rough
avec le break site
les irlandais voient leur premier
partenaire commercial en europe quitter
le marché commun pour eux il s'agit de
trouver de nouveaux alliés dans l'union
européenne
c'est l'argument de campagne des
centristes du fine gael le parti au
pouvoir
plusieurs fois ministre francis
fitzgerald est candidate à dublin
nous allons devoir bâtir de nouvelles
relations
par exemple avec la france autour de
l'agriculture mais aussi avec d'autres
petits états et les états d'europe du
nord avec qui nous avons des intérêts
communs
c'est sans doute l'élection européenne
la plus importante pour l'irlande depuis
qu'elle a rejoint le jeu car le scénario
vient de changer et nous allons dépendre
davantage des autres pays européens
ne cherchez pas de camp anti européens
en irlande même les nationalistes du
sinn fein ranger à gauche est longtemps
opposée à l'europe ont mis de l'eau dans
leur vin
alors que le break site ravivent le
spectre du conflit nord-irlandais
ses défenseurs historique de
l'indépendance voient en lui le meilleur
garant pour protéger la paix doivent
reconnaître que l'europe a été ferme
vis-à-vis du royaume-uni
quel à veiller aux intérêts de l'irlande
dans les récentes négociations afin de
protéger nos accords de paix et éviter
le retour à une frontière dur avec
l'irlande du nord
conséquence du break site l'élection
européenne change en tout cas de
dimension en irlande
dans le passé les élections européennes
était considérée ici comme des élections
de second rang mais avec le break site
et toute notre attention est focalisée à
bruxelles je pense que les irlandais
vont accorder beaucoup plus d'importance
à ces élections européennes
hasard du calendrier
l'élection européenne coïncide avec une
période de grande incertitude pour
l'irlande
plus que jamais son regard est tourné
vers l'europe
et pour en discuter j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir sur ce plateau angélique
delahaye bonjour bonjour vous êtes
française membre du parti populaire
européen à vos côtés aujourd'hui jean
lambert bonjour vous êtes britannique
membre du groupe des verts dans ce
parlement européen et pour compléter ce
plateau j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir
jennifer baker bonjour vous êtes
irlandaise et vous travailler ici à
bruxelles en tant que journaliste depuis
une petite dizaine d'années alors la
première question inévitablement elle va
porter sur le brési temps on l'a vu dans
le sujet c'est un sujet omniprésent en
irlande 1 mais ce chaos autour du brésil
semble renforcer le sentiment européen
dans ce pays vous le comprenez à jean
lambert wilson on sait que en irlande on
sent que l'union européenne
vraiment on dit de protéger irlande dans
cette situation de l'accueillir vraiment
est un sage ça je crois que c'est très
important de voir ça d'être là d'être
protégé comme un petit pays et ça c'est
très bien pour quoi l'image de l'europe
alors le sentiment européen en irlande
il est tellement fort qu'on trouve pas
finalement vraiment de discours
eurosceptiques même chez les
nationalistes mais ça fait quand même
plutôt figure d'exception angélique
delahaye en europe oui c'est vrai mais
je crois que ça se comprend par
l'histoire même de l'irlande et de cette
paix qui est quand même assez récente
1 évidemment dans d'autres pays
européens comme la france on n'a pas ce
vécu et puis ça fait soixante dix ans
qu'on vit en paix donc finalement c'est
devenu un acquis or je crois que la paix
nous devons la concevoir comme étant une
nécessité mais que rien n'est jamais
acquis il suffit de regarder aux
frontières de l'europe ce qui se passe
pour comprendre que la paix est quelque
chose de fragile qu'il faut continuer à
cultiver en europe et que la seule
protection à cette paix les irlandais
bien l'ont bien dit dans ce documentaire
c'est l'europe ait une europe unifiée et
et pacifiées alors justement un jennifer
biker est-ce qu'il ya d'autres raisons
que le breakbeat des raisons historiques
justement pour expliquer ce sentiment
très européen en iran
oui bien sûr pour ma génération en avoir
toujours pendant les années 80 des
affiches partout
cette passe se troue cet espace faire
n'importe quoi étaient fondées été payés
par l'union européenne et on a toujours
l'idée que l'europe nous aide au niveau
financier
et bien sûr il faut admettre que le
président fait un nouveau niveau de
coopération et même que l'on n'est pas
le plus grand pays
c'est vraiment notable qu'il est que les
autres membres ils ont nous était très
favorable
et enfin nous sommes un pays d
émigration et pour ça je crois qu'il y
ait un sens entre les irlandais qu'il
faut être très proches évacué trois ans
avec le monde entière parce que on sait
lequel elle aussi oui mais parce qu'un
jour il faut nous déprendre vivre là bas
et ça c'est pourquoi aussi il n'y a pas
de cap tennis main dans les landes
alors on le rappelle aussi avec le
brésil c'est la menace du retour d'une
frontière physique entre les deux
irlande 1 qui fait le plus peur
évidemment une menace sur les accords du
vendredi saint on en a parlé qui avaient
mis fin à 30 ans de guerre civile dans
le pays
que se passerait-il en cas de sortie
sans accord d'une lamberti sans accord
serait très difficile en sait on ce pas
vraiment on sait que on doit avoir une
frontière de quelque sorte à une
frontière plus dur pour question de
dédouaner 720 et ça ça serait très
difficile je crois parce que c'est
difficile pour le commerce
c'est difficile pour les gens de dans la
vie quotidienne et sa mairie de 6,7 pc
wii est aussi pour la paix parce que
c'est pas ça - frontières physiques mais
c'est aussi français et écologique
alors la france a adopté un ton
particulièrement dure vis-à-vis des
britanniques lors du dernier conseil
européen
est-ce qu'il faut que ça cesse l'on vous
angélique delahaye écouter
moi je considère que les peuples sont
souverains et donc les britanniques ont
pris une décision c'est leur choix
on peut déplorer ce choix pour autant
aujourd'hui la décision leur appartient
je crois qu'il ya un moment il faut que
et il faut que les l'europe soit
cohérente et michel barnier a quand même
mis large de la corne
il ya 27 pays qui sont unies derrière
cet accord je pense que les britanniques
l'ont parfaitement compris
aujourd'hui deux scénarios possibles
c'est à eux que revient le choix est
donc que la france ait un temps durs ne
me semble pas forcément la bonne manière
je crois que maintenant il est temps de
se taire et de d'attendre la décision
que prendront les paieries tannique sur
les deux scénarii qui se profile alors
justement un s'il prône aussi le propose
quelque chose de véritablement nouveau
et sous réserve de leur participation
aux élections européennes
les britanniques pourraient obtenir un
report au long du brésil probablement
jusqu'à la fin de cette année qu'est ce
que cela signifierait pour les irlandais
jennifer becker ce sera encore de longs
mois d'incertitude j'imagine c'est vrai
que les hollande c'est le pays le plus
affectueux et plus touchées par le bug
dit
mais le nord de l'irlande c'est leur
région le plus affecté ma famille est
d'origine belfast dans le nord de
londres j'ai passé toute mon enfance on
creuse et le frontières physiques et les
gens qui habitent part par là ils ont
été en culture de peur thème culture
violente et personne veut retourner à ça
et je crois que pour ça il faut être
patiente
même si les britanniques demandent
encore notre de l'est
c'est mieux d'avoir un budget dans un
manner gérer mais en même temps il faut
demande encore anne de l'est c'est
pourquoi est-ce que c'est mérité est ce
qu'il ya un plan et ce qui est une idée
que faire alors il ya un secteur aussi
qu'ils seraient particulièrement
affectées qui sera particulièrement
affecté par le brésil c'est
l'agriculture je rappelle que 37 % des
exportations agroalimentaires irlandaise
parts au royaume uni donc ce serait un
double défi puisque le brésil ça
signifie aussi une réduction du budget
européen notamment du budget de la pac
de la politique agricole commune c'est
un autre grand sujet d'inquiétude en
irlande j'imaginais angélique delahaye
oui alors moi je
permettez moi d'avoir une position un
peu différente sur le budget de la bac
moi je veux bien qu'on se batte pour le
budget de la pac pour le budget de la
pac mais moi ma philosophie se dire
finalement quelle politique agricole
souhaitons bout et en fonction des
outils dont nous avons besoin à ce
moment là on pourra discuter d'un budget
or j'ai un peu l'impression qu'un ami un
peu la charrue avant les boeufs alors là
c'est mon côté un peu agricultrice qui
parle moi je laboure avant de récolter
et donc je considère qu'il faut avoir un
vrai projet pour l'agriculture
alors on va revenir à l'irlande on l'a
vu dans le reportage dans nos débats que
les irlandais étaient très pro européens
mais il ya peut-être un sujet sur lequel
est bien se tourner vers l'europe c'est
la fiscalité en puisque l'union
européenne aimerait mettre en place des
règles communes en matière de fiscalité
mais l'irlande tient à son taux
d'imposition des sociétés à 2 5% kienlen
verte
question difficile parce que on sait
bien que beaucoup de choses qu'on peut
faire au niveau européen mais pour nous
c'est ça le plus important d'avoir quoi
un bad fiscalité pour comme ça et en ce
moment c'était très difficile de faire
bouger les irlandais parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de choses qui bougent à ya
beaucoup d'aidé financière que viennent
maintenant en irlande mais je voudrais
bien que il ya des voies de dire longue
pour dire oui il faut faire plus niveau
national et
niveau européen alors ça ne s'est pas
seulement irlande et à ses problèmes
alors c'est important de dire aussi que
c'est cette fiscalité avantageuse
finalement qui génère des flux de
capitaux en irlande et conséquence
l'irlande affiche une bonne croissance
6,7 pour cent en 2018 tout juste cinq
ans après le plan de l'aide
internationale à la suite de la crise
financière
dublin attire particulièrement les gars
fin on vous disait jennifer baker c'est
aussi comme j'ai dit que nous sommes en
europe il nous voir comme une porte à
l'europe et aussi peut-être d autres
choses dans le demain de régulation par
exemple une approche peut-être un peu
plus légère sur le protection des
données par rapport à d autres
juridictions
alors il ya un état membre un
particulièrement actif sur la question
dégâts face à la france 1 devant
l'inertie de certains pays européens le
ministre de l'économie français a même
évacuer la solution européenne au profit
d'une solution nationale
écoutez nous créons aujourd'hui cette
taxation des plus grandes entreprises
numériques
au niveau national cette taxe elle est
simple elle est ciblée elle est efficace
elle est simple puisque elle aura un
taux unique 3 % sur le chiffre
d'affaires numérique réalisée en france
c'est exactement la même base que le
projet que nous portons à l'échelle de
l'union européenne alors la france n'est
pas la seule
il ya aussi le royaume uni l'espagne et
l'autriche qui ont légiféré pour taxer
les gars fin à ces géants du web
américain
c'est une preuve selon vous angélique
delahaye de l'impossibilité s'entendre
au niveau européen en tous les cas c'est
une preuve de l'isolément de la france
qui n'a pas a priori était capable de
convaincre les autres états membres dans
une majorité plus conséquents puisque
vous avez cité quelques états membres
c'est loin de faire la majorité des
états membres
moi je suis assez inquiète parce que on
a un gouvernement qui se dit prêt
européen et qui met de côté la solution
d'une négociation au plan européen pour
j'allais dire entraîné avec elle
d'autres états pour la mise en place
d'une et commandité cancer thème
réformes sont complètement bloqués au
niveau européen écoutez
c'est toute la force de la diplomatie où
on l'a où on l'a pas manifestement la
fin alors pour finir je voudrais que
l'on évoque les dernières évolutions sur
les questions sociétales en irlande
écoutons d'abord cette candidate du
parti de centre-droit à l'élection
européenne que l'on a déjà vu dans le
reportage
je suis très impressionné par le bilan
européen
vous savez quand j'ai commencé en
politique ou même quand j'étais engagé
dans les organisations de femmes avant
d'entrer en politique
d'où est venue l'égalité d'où est venue
l'égalité pour les femmes irlandaises
c'est venu de l'europe c'est venu par
l'égalité salariale par l'europe
le gouvernement de l'époque avait dit
non nous ne pouvons pas nous le
permettre
l'europe a insisté alors encore une fois
un sentiment à 13 européen est ce que
pour vous tenir baker c'est l'europe qui
a permis ces avancées sur le plan
sociétal on pense notamment au
référendum sur l'avortement qui a été
libéralisé en irlande au début de
l'année oui mais pas plus que ça a été
aussi levé frendo en solo
l'égalité pour les mariages qui touchent
la communauté lgbt sur le blasphème
également geox et 6,6 hors d'europe mais
de le monde frontières je crois que
l'internet a fait un bond différentes
parmi les irlandais et
ils ont embrassé la modernité dans des
idées de tout le monde international et
c'est ça qui accueillera nouveau société
qui est ouverte plus tolérante et bon je
suis j'ai assez optimistic un pays donc
en pleine mutation mais face aux défis
du breakbeat on en reparlera d'ici le 26
mai merci beaucoup à tout les trois
d'avoir été nos invités merci à vous de
nous avoir suivis à la semaine prochaine
pour un nouveau numéro d' europe hebdo
[Musique]
oh